what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and as spider-man
knowing home is about to come out on
digital release and blu-ray we're
getting to see some deleted scenes that
were cut from the movie and today we
have a deleted scene that was revealed
in a photo that was revealed from sony
and marvel studios we're going to break
down that scene but first i know a lot
of people were expecting some marvel
stuff to happen from disney plus's
investor day or i guess it was just
disney's annual shareholders meeting
unfortunately we didn't really get much
from marvel we did get a little bit of a
glimpse at a few new scenes for miss
marvel and she-hulk but it was only
seconds long and it's footage that we
can't really post online because it's
copyrighted but you didn't really miss
anything nothing was really revealed
unfortunately we did get the kenobi star
wars obi-wan kenobi series trailer that
was pretty epic but unfortunately
not that much for marvel they did talk
about
how doctor strange was going to be a
huge movie though and that how it's
going to connect marvel in ways it
hasn't before
kind of hinting out of course you know
the x-men and fantastic four and
everybody that's rumored to you know be
cameoing but unfortunately they didn't
reveal much for marvel they just kind of
teased miss marvel and she-hulk a little
bit so sorry about that looks like we're
gonna have to wait a little bit longer
to get more new trailers from marvel
studios and i know we're waiting for
that thor love and thunder trailer
hopefully soon but let's talk about this
new spider-man no way home deleted scene
that we just discovered and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
now we have one photo of a deleted scene
and a few behind the scenes photos as
well that are really cool showing toby
andrew and of course tom but here is the
picture of a deleted scene that was
supposed to happen on the way up to
happy's apartment
[Music]
here we can see all of the villains
minus the lizard who decided to stay in
the van downstairs outside going up to
the apartment where peter parker is
going to try and fix them now not much
is really known about this scene but i'm
sure it would have been simply a 5 to 10
second scene of silence just them
writing up in the elevator awkwardly
perhaps some elevator music in the
background maybe one person said
something that was comedy related but
what's actually really interesting about
this is that there's really no reason
for them to have cut this out i mean i'm
not the filmmaker i don't know why this
was cut but it seems like it would have
only been 5 seconds 10 seconds long but
perhaps it threw something off perhaps
the tone or the pacing during this
moment but i'm sure it would have been a
cool little 5-10 second clip that
unfortunately we were robbed of but it
looks like this is going to be coming
out in the deleted scene section when
spider-man no way home hits digital and
blu-ray and like i mentioned we also
have some behind-the-scenes photos
released we have some of toby and andrew
toby himself and tom himself with the
goblin on the goblin's glider this is no
doubt the scene where peter is holding
onto the goblin's glider he takes one of
the pumpkin bombs shoves it inside one
of the little engines and causes it to
explode and they both fall to the ground
and that's where we get that final fight
then of course we have one with toby and
andrew on the statue of liberty
scaffolding honestly every picture that
we see of toby and andrew together is
just fantastic they're all just awesome
and i can't wait to see more behind the
scene photos i can't wait to see behind
the scenes videos and deleted scenes
between the two of them as well and the
three spider-man there's another one of
the two of them and this seems to be
after toby gets stabbed this looks like
it could be right before they say
goodbye to each other or i should say
wave and do the peace sign to each other
and then the last behind the scenes
photo is of tobey maguire back in his
spider-man suit which is just phenomenal
i love seeing toby back in the suit i
love that in some interviews he stated
that he's all about it he's so excited
to be back in the suit and i really hope
that means he's going to be returning
for other spider-man films so there you
have it one deleted scene revealed and a
picture for it given to us and four
behind the scenes photos of spiderman no
way home let me know what you think
about all of these in the comments down
below and don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all of these other deleted scenes and
bts photos that will be coming out for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you